hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar advances and challenges in
laboratory rodent management inter a our
situation with emphasis in Bavaria
condition surgery anesthesia and
euthanasia I am Christina mihalik
survivors and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of their children in webinars
advancements scientific collaboration
and learning it's brought to you by
libraries to learn more visit Lavery's
com let's get started you can post
questions to the speakers during the
presentation what are their fresh in
your mind to do so simply type them into
the Q&A box which will open when you
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you experience has no problem seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button sounds at the top
right of the presentation window or
report the problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on this button located
in the bottom left hand corner of your
web page and follow the process of
obtaining your credit it is now my
pleasure to present today's speaker
Jessica Dipple CBM in FCP HD animal
welfare officer pause official Catholic
University of Tel a doctor simple
graduated as a vest from the universidad
de 2a
and after a couple of years working with
South America and camelids in north of
Chile went to the UK where she did a MSP
in bio integrated science and then
graduated as a PhD at the University of
Oxford her research there was about the
effects of housing in hubba hubba injury
on welfare of lavatory primates users
behavioral and non-invasive indicators
of welfare on her return to Chile she
worked at the National Zoo implementing
environmental enrichment in teaching
animal behavior and welfare at the
caucus Catholic universities PCP you see
dr. Dibble now works full time at the
medicine ask us at the medicine at
faculty PUC where she is responsible for
the welfare of animals used in research
she is in charge of the animal facility
as well as supervising compliance within
the institution's animal care program
she also teaches and trains students NP
is about animal use in research both
from an ethical at a practical point of
view she is a member of the
institutional scientific ethics
committee for the care and use of
animals in research of the pontifical
pakka official Catholic University of
Calais in that role she collaborates in
the development of regulations to carry
out the ethical evaluation in
implementation of project post-approval
monitoring she is an active member of
the Chilean Society of laboratory animal
sciences whose main objective is to
improve standards of care in the use of
animals in research to pick an animal
welfare as central to their work she is
also an ad hoc member of a lack doctor
given a burden her presentation thank
you hi everyone first of all I would
like to thank the organizers for this
invitation
it is a special thanks because three
years now they have been following our
process in chilling this is the third
time we participate telling you the
audience about how we have been
implementing animal care programs in
order to improve animal well sir of
laboratory animals and the quality of
research both at our institution the
pontifical catholic university of chile
and also spreading our knowledge and
experience to the rest of our colleagues
in the country so the aims of this talk
are to provide an overview of the main
challenges and advances of animal
research in a developing country like
ours with evolving regulations and in
that way to increase awareness of the
need we all have of standards
harmonization in laboratory animal
research between developed and
developing countries given the
increasing importance of globalization
and international collaborations we all
want our work to be worth to be of high
quality while at the same time we would
like to respect and avoid unnecessary
suffering of our subjects of study
laboratory animals so first of all let
me give you some context of the way
things are in Chile we are a distant and
small country but we do perform
important research and have established
interesting international collaboration
links with researchers in North America
Europe and other regions of the world in
terms of the use of animals for research
we don't have official statistics
actually we don't have any about how
many animals are useful research in
Chile nor do we know the proportion of
animals used in code for each type of
research as I was saying we don't have
any statistic about about those numbers
as there is no authority designated to
collect that information so this slide
here is just for you to get an overview
of what we do basic and biomedical
research
we use most of the animals that go into
research there are several universities
with strong teams of investigators in
basic and Applied Sciences just mention
one neuroscience is the strong and
productive field of research in our
country there are also many scientists
conducting research about important
human illnesses such as degenerative and
chronic diseases as well as infectious
one in addition Chile has very strict
regulations for protecting farm animals
health for example in powder industry
some situations have such as potential
disease outbreaks imply the use of very
high numbers of animals in order to
perform very rapid diagnostic tests
therefore our farm animal health service
[ __ ] breeds large stocks of potentially
necessary animals for those diagnostic
purposes also for toxicology diagnosis
we have more than 4,000 kilometres of
coastline that is continuously monitored
for the appearance of red tide a toxin
carried by the shellfish that is
potentially lethal for human consumption
so all extracted stock of shellfish must
be tested continuously this means the
breeding and use of high numbers of mind
for those purposes some of our advantage
with all those animals being used for
research fortunately we have had
important advances in the last decade
the first research ethics committees
were formed to comply with international
requirements for collaboration with
foreign institutions such as d NIH for
example and about the same time our
national scientific research funding
agency also set ethics evaluation as a
requirement for all projects using
animals our animal protection law
established in 2009 covers all types of
animal using ie the farm animals pets
wild and zoo animals and also animals
in scientific research that section of
the law defines what is covered by this
regulation basically everything within
research and education where animals are
used even non interventional studies
such as behavioral observation it
defines who can do it stating that
researchers must have appropriate
training and it also defines that
facilities must be adequate for each
species all of this is aimed at avoiding
unnecessary suffering so all of this is
in fact an important advance however the
bad news for us who work in laboratory
animals here is what regulations in
order to implement that looks are not
working yet fully in place below is a
very general text but the actual
detailed regulations to make it work
have still not been put in place
therefore even though the laws state
that someone working with animals and
scientific procedures must have
appropriate training it is not defined
what actually what that actually
involves it this implies that there are
no officially recognized courses about
experimental animal care this also means
that there is no official control of how
animals are actually used so at last
animal clear animal 30-12 last animal
use and care depends on each institution
and how seriously this issue is taken
fortunately more and more institutions
and scientists themselves understanding
how the quality of research is affected
by the conditions in which laboratory
animals are kept and how procedures are
carried out I am fortunate to work at a
university that takes research quality
very seriously and is not only
allocating considerable funds into
improving laboratory animal housing
conditions but also setting up a central
ethical review body this means now all
faculties and research centers are
the Catholic University of Chile must go
through a thorough evaluation with the
same standard for the whole institution
and this is before any work with animals
is that so our aya cooks at national
level or how we call them see koalas
this is just a literal translation of
aya cook they are in many institutions
already they have been progressively
implementing their own research ethics
kinetic committees and we have also
formed our national laboratory animal
science association a surgical and
become members of our regional
federation called vesicle and members of
the international council for laboratory
animal science a class we have had to I
o'clock national meetings and are
planning the third one for this year as
you can see in this table we get an
important number of attendants coming
from different backgrounds academia
government institutions and private
organizations the purpose of this of the
first national meeting that we held back
in 2013 was to get to know each other
from sorry and to form a national
network and to try to standardize
criteria for ethical and animal welfare
evaluation of research project using
animals our first step then was to agree
on having a national forum that
researchers have to fill and submit to
their committee I have to say that this
is not official so there is not an
actual document as a national forum as
there is in other countries but in
practice we all have the same questions
in it with only small differences so
even though the law is still not working
properly through agreement and
productivity we have managed to work in
a row
unified way in order to prepare for our
first national meeting and in 2013 we
ran an online survey and at that time
and some of you might have seen some of
these graphs re in an earlier by a
conference so I'm not going to show you
all of them again but but just a few to
give you more context I apologize on the
graph are so small and not sure if you
can actually see them properly but I
will try to go briefly over the most
important facts that i want to show you
these graphs represent how the I acute
situation was before we started our
national network so we wanted to get
that Janelle picture of that the first
one shows that at the time at that time
most simply institutions have their
committees in place over ninety percent
sorry forgot I don't have a but my mouth
is not a pointer so this one over ninety
percent of institutions with their I
occurred in place and also that let me
see if this works here but over sixty
percent where and sorry institutional so
they depended on central authority
this one here shows that we found that
just over sixty percent were able to
take resolutions and they were not
completely able to carry out their
mission another problem reflecting the
lack of adequate function in our opinion
was that seventy percent of them did not
have an established frequency of
meetings but had sessions only when they
needed to evaluate projects this of
course did not allow for the the other
functions functions of an ayah cook to
be in place such as periodically
checking facilities and post-approval
monitoring so this is where we started
to work together in order to harmonize
what our aya cooks were doing and keep
working on that in line with that work a
couple of months ago not sure what do
you need confusional in lines of that
work a couple of months ago I hurried
out national online survey to find out
about general characteristics of roading
housing conditions in our country as you
may imagine this is sensitive
information and it is not easy to obtain
especially given that we do not have any
mandate to register Bavaria nor an
authority that collects this data
therefore for this kind of survey we
depend on goodwill and on the trust
built through our national network and
years of working already as well as the
notion that we are all working to
improve our national standards regarding
laboratory animal welfare hence the
purpose of this survey was to estimate
the variability of ivory conditions in
order to have data to show storages and
government decision makers in animal
research the potential effect on
experimental results due to the lack of
standardization in these matters
engineering the survey was carried out
using survey monkey butt
depants were sent an email explaining
the aim of the survey and inviting them
to respond anonymously the invitation
was sent out to 35 x value managers from
academic private and government
institutions 30 replies were received so
we think this is a good estimation of
what we have today this isn't public
published yet and I am NOT going to show
you all the results that brinkley go
over some of the facts that appeared
interesting to me bear in mind that all
these questions refer to standards
mountain maintenance conditions of rats
and mice I not during experimental
procedures that might imply special
conditions in the first graph we can see
the type of caging that is used for rats
and mice forty-six percent are
polycarbonate static pages twenty
percent police often static cages and
eighteen percent of our replies and said
that they used individually ventilated
cages tiny CC I honestly thought that
the oldest cages that we had in the
country where those men made of glass
fiber that we still see and some
vivarium but was surprised to see that
there are still some Riveria that keep
animals in metal cages both with solid
and wire mesh floor nearly eight percent
of replied the second graph shows that
in the type of shows that in the type of
cage cleaning and disinfection there is
also important variability in the
practices difference I've area youth for
example sixteen percent for only washing
each time the kate is changed the
majority wash and bandage infect cages
using chemical disinfectants this is
fifty two percent and sixteen percent
autoclave the cages
each time they change them here are the
data for the type of diet and water
provided to rub my fortunately in terms
of diet there has been a change in the
last five years moving from a national
diet to certified imported diet however
there are still thirty percent of
bavaria using this very poor quality
national diet and i say this responsibly
this is a bad light in nutritional and
microbiological terms regarding water
thirty-eight percent of our area used
non-treated sorry this is the graph
non-treated tap water and then there is
all the spectrum of filtered tap water
distilled water autoclaved water
nineteen percent and acidified water
throughout process again a lot of
variability there regarding staff and
this is the only question in the survey
that is the same as the one with it in
2013 the staff working and they are just
considering the decisions of a vet still
we find somewhere very that have no vet
working with them as it is anonymous we
don't know if these are the same three
places or or is there others and but
this is another matter that legislation
should solve what happens our array at
our institution the Catholic University
of Chile I am fortunate to work in a
university that has realized the
importance of improved and standardize
conditions for research animals and so
has embarked on a long-term project for
new animal care facilities and the
implementation of a proper Animal Care
program with the aim of applying
for accreditation when the whole system
is working for this we are in the
process of building a new central
vivarium where all the breeding will
take place and to satellite for housing
and carrying out experimental protocols
they will all work with standardized
operational procedures and have SPF
animals we are training our staff which
means continuously training ourselves as
well within this program we have
recently started an initiative to run on
site courses about experimental animal
care in the main regions of our country
given that we have realized that this
can help speed up changes more rapidly
because we can reach out to more people
in each facility then when we run four
courses in santiago and hope that people
from the regions will be able to spare a
week from work to attend those courses
here in San Cielo so this is a big
challenge that we have in both of our
selves at the Catholic University and we
do it because we believe at that
conditions and practices have to improve
and hopefully we can help with that too
we are moving from this sort of very
conventional accommodations with open
static police often cages to this this
is the sort of new facility that we are
building these pictures are from our
transition facility that is that has
only I VCS and operates with all these
standardized procedures it has been
running for more than a year now while
building of the new central vivarium is
taking place and it has been a good
progressive learning experience and
training opportunity for ourselves and
our staff to now to get into more
specific matters such as the advantage
advantages and challenges we face in the
practice of surgery analgesia anesthesia
this is a process that of course
replicates what I was telling you at the
beginning of this book and it is on the
pier
by the lack of implementation of the
existing law but at the same time by the
willingness of individual institutions
who want to make progress in order to
improve animal welfare and the quality
of their research our aya cook asks now
for very detailed information in the
process of research project evaluation
the first thing is to adequately justify
the procedure or to consider replacement
and I'll come back to this in the next
slide we also asked for the information
related to type and dose of anesthesia
and analgesia description of the
surgical room where the procedure will
take place the previous training of
researchers that will perform surgery
what sort of intra-operative support
they will give animals as well as
post-operative care and the type of
frequency of monitor of monitoring the
animals after the surgical procedure we
even asked them not to perform surgery
after Wednesday's because we are aware
of staff limitations that make it
difficult to supervise animals through
weekend as I was saying we asked for
appropriate justification and as such
there are many procedures especially for
surgical training that now avoid the use
of animal models by using different
kinds of simulation here we see part of
the center of simulation of our medicine
school that was officially opened last
year even though part of it had already
been running for some years training
surgeons can now practice here and some
of them back our team of plastic
surgeons have become very creative and
resourceful and have designed a
microsurgery course using commercial
commercial chicken blood vessels to
practice for things as arterial
anastomosis they have demonstrated
through a project funded funded by our
medical school that the learning curve
is at least as good as when working with
live animals so this is what they use
now to claim specialists here
we can observe one of these practices in
the picture of the right at this point
please allow me to for me to tell you a
personal anecdote two weeks ago had a
serious full at work and cut my lip
quite badly I was taken to the emergency
of our university hospital to have my
face and lips tutored I was really proud
and happy to see a young resident
plastic surgeon that I had lectured
about experimental animal care and who
is now part of what we colloquially here
called the chicken wing project he was
the one who made my stitches and if you
could now look at my face we couldn't
tell I had such a bad one two weeks ago
a lot of the of his good skills were
learned through replacement he's
actually the one doing that anastomosis
in the picture of the right I am really
proud of that in this picture you can
see the experimental medicine surgery
room in the Center for medical research
where I am based we work not only with
mice and rats but also with swine and
sometimes sheet so these surgical rooms
are big and adaptable for the range of
animal size that we manage
this is the kind of equipment our
researchers use nowadays we still have a
long way to make more progress but we
believe that believe me this is already
very different to the basic equipment
they used to have only some years ago
many research teams now use inhaled
anesthesia thermal platforms with
integrated temperature monitoring in
order to keep the animal temperature
well regulated during surgical
procedures and through our persistent
our advice and believe me I can be very
persistent they have started acquiring
physiological monitors to control
intra-operative values this is also
greatly influenced by the work of our I
ACOG through post-approval monitoring
where rate of failure or mortality rates
are monitored another advanced i am that
i am happy to share with you is our
constant effort to make to improve
training hands-on training surgical
courses have become valuable tools to
gradually change investigators outdated
and tradition based surgical practices
these pictures are from a workshop we
had in 2014 when dr. Michelle Perez
genteel came to our University for a
week and run a series of different
practical modules teaching not only
about specific procedures like the one
shown on the slide but also emphasizing
the importance of effective techniques
aseptic technique animal preparation and
post-operative care Marcel has been
drivin chillin out running these courses
and as far as I know he's coming back
this year so we're very happy to have
him again in here I have to say how
grateful we are about his generosity
with his knowledge and how inspiring he
is yesterday we heard mr. fleegle about
the importance of having good trainers
and how it is not just about you being
very good at surgery or about a
particular technique but how you are
able
to transmit that knowledge myself red
and teal is one of those persons a very
good trainer and I thank him for that
well as also Marcel was telling us
yesterday in his book some researchers
keep outdated practices and do not pay
proper attention to fundamental issues
such as a sceptic techniques experience
has taught us here that a good solution
to that when no other other argument is
accepted is to have evidence-based
arguments this is a picture of an animal
that had finished experimental protocol
and was used a knife to obtain tissues
that did not involve the site of a
previous surgery that had taken place
three weeks earlier according to the
investigator this animal was absolutely
ok after that I did not agree because I
have seen some signs in this rats
behavior and fur covered so I performed
a necropsy in the side of surgery in
this way I was able to show their
researcher the evidence that his
surgical practice was not really
adequate I have to say that fortunately
this is an old picture and I have not
found anything like this ever again so
we are confident that we are making
progress I only show it because I think
it is a good tool that one can use when
bad or outdated practices are not easy
to to get changed
guarding analgesia an advanced have been
the inclusion of more alternative to
users analgesics the traditions again
that rule before I acocks came into
place was to use what the particular lab
had always used sometimes that meant no
analgesia sometimes only one
non-steroidal anti-inflammatory agent
the challenge for us was to change the
idea that all analgesics will affect
experimental protocol and data and data
and thus it is better not to use them
some of this is true but nowadays the
effect and magnitude of particular drugs
on specific metabolic paths are known
which is better than having the effect
of pain where we face unknown levels of
pain and often tremendous effects on
physiology our advance on that is to
offer alternatives of analgesics not
just the one non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drugs but also opioids
that affect different pathways still if
an investigator / fists on the idea of
not using any analgesia then our I
o'clock asks to justify the argument
with a pilot showing the evidence that
the specific parameter studied in those
that in their research is indeed
affected as also shown on this slide we
place emphasis on post surgical
monitoring and playing them to use
specific tools such as the mouse and the
red grimace scale we also encourage
investigators to use pre-emptive
analgesia
as I mentioned earlier the use of
inhaled anesthesia has increased the
last couple of years this is partly due
to the technical advice from that
emphasizing the advantages of inhaled /
injected anesthesia this has helped to
gradually change the traditional
researchers view and they have started
to realize that inhaled anesthesia
equipment is an investment rather than a
cost when they see how mortality rates
drop drastically when changing from
injected to inhaled anesthesia and all
the work money and animal life saved by
this more modern anesthesia application
lastly we have placed emphasis to on
euthanasia method teaching investigators
which methods are acceptable acceptable
with conditions and unacceptable we know
this is not a nice subject and therefore
in some cases it is neglect neglected to
touch on this issue but i believe it is
so crucial that it has to be one of the
main subjects of training in animal care
courses not all animals that we breed
our house will actually be in an
experimental protocol nor have surgery
or even samples taking taken during
their life but all of our experimental
animals will undergo and will undergo a
user nation hence it has to be a central
concern and all people working with
experimental animals must have some kind
of training about it not just the ones
that will actually perform that
procedure and this does not only
referred to the methods but also the
training of you to use an Asian what
happens when cages are accumulated in a
different room for euthanasia of excess
animals what happens when a humane point
is reached if the animal has to wait for
it because other daily routine practices
are considered more important at that
time then we are in trouble
climbing is an important issue in
information so these are some of the
concepts I try to convey when I trained
investigators and stuff an important
part of this training our workshops not
just lectures where I tell them what is
appropriate but workshops where we can
discuss issues because euthanasia is an
issue in itself for many people and
because it is an evolving issue every
year we get more evidence of this and
that method being more or less
appropriate also hands-on practical
sessions in order to learn how to do it
properly and how to recognize when it is
nothing adequately apart from the
training that I do at my university last
couple of years I have been running
these workshops in other institutions
and you can see in this slide the
numbers of attendance the one in 2016
was an internal workshop for sag this is
our national farm animal health
authority remember I told you at the
beginning large numbers of animals are
used there for diagnostic purposes there
for euthanasia is a big issue for them
too and I am glad that they now have an
AI occurred in place that was able to
recognize that need for training the
staff of [ __ ] so I hope have achieved
some of the aims of this talk by giving
you an overview of our challenges and
advances all of them require a strong
institutional support and the certainty
that research quality improves when
animal welfare is brought into the
equation it is true that we have a lack
of implementation of our legislation but
we have shown that we can still do
important progress while waiting to that
to happen
finally I hope this hook with this took
it has also it has become once again as
you probably know it already the
importance of the need of standard
harmonisation in laboratory animal
research between developed and
developing countries thanks for taking
the time for listening to this tool
thank you dr. temple for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
please simply type them in the Q&A box
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the present
presentation1 doubt he is out dr. Gimple
will answer as many questions as time
permits so please do go ahead and submit
your question
okay it looks as though we don't have
any questions today but I we're going to
thank you thank dr. get before her time
dr. Gabe will do you have any closing
statement thank you are just to thank
the audience I know it to find out about
the reality of other countries must be
something that is not on your daily
desires but I think it's wonderful that
over 40 people have been listening to
this so I am available for if anyone has
comments afterwards they can contact me
thank you very much again for attending
this okay well thank you so much
actually dr. caball we've literally just
got in a question if you don't mind
answering the question asks out what are
we doing to further emitted to move
further towards improvements ensure a
well as I was saying we are working
together the members of aya cooks and
also the people who work at vivarium
because we come together in the national
laboratory animal science association we
regularly hold meetings and courses to
train ourselves and as the law is still
not working properly because all the
rules are not in place so to say for
example how much training someone needs
or what is a certified animal care
course so in the national laboratory
animal Association what we've been doing
is to drag those rules that will enable
the law to work what is lacking is to
have a national ethics committee that
was set out and in the animal protection
law and it even has the post of the
people who should be cold therefore that
national committee but that national
committee is still not in place and they
are the ones that should be writing the
norms that with will make this part of
the law work for us and we've been
waiting for that to happen for years now
so we've gone ahead and drafted all the
rules that this law should contain and
have them ready for when that committee
is formed so that they can work with
that oh thank you dr. gamble for
answering that last-minute question and
I'd also like to thank the audience for
joining us today additionally your bike
to take Lavery's for making today's
educational webcast possible this lab
tests can be
dude on the Ventura July 2017 lab roots
will alert you be email what it is
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed it today this is
Christina will see you next you next
time here at lab roots goodbye